coats of yours you said i'm not a point
guard i'm a killer
i want you to tell me five guys playing
right now you're like they're killers
steph curry
kevin durant
james harden
um
james harden oh what's the smile for
because i know a lot of killers yeah um
bradley bill he's a killer
oh
dang
dang dang dame's the killer certified
yeah
certified oh why are you getting so
excited about dane what about dame cause
dame just he's a monster with it like
he's he's um he's kind of
steph is just
just bad as hell
but
damn just so rude [ __ ] like he
just rude he's just disrespectful he
just do anything just
i mean
pass half court and just let it fly
buzzer beat us he
at the hash you know what i mean just
like
no fear no i mean just nothing he's a
he's not just a killer he's a serial
killer
[Laughter]
that's so good
vicious
yeah big shout out
you know speaking of dame i also asked
dame if he had a question for you and i
have one from him as well um which
actually makes me think of another one
of your quotes which was when someone
asked you about coaching you said i'm
coaching because i don't want to coach
no [ __ ] make more money than me
right
does that say does that stand yeah
because i mean i'm just saying it's like
it's like
i always got i have the utmost respect
for coaches in the nba yeah and just i
mean coaches worldwide but in the nba
it's totally different like you you have
all of these guys making all this money
everybody on the team make more money
than you and you're able honestly you're
able to bring these guys together and
get them to believe in one thing yeah
and that's playing the right way and
winning and having them
all with the same mindset and the same
goal
in their head and they buy into it you
know what i mean to ultimately win a
championship you know what i mean that's
power yeah and that's respect you know
what i mean when you got these guys
you know they make all this money
and they buying in everything that you
know
that you say and and this is a lot of
guys you got guys on different teams
with max contracts that they probably
feel like you know they supposed to be
the man yeah but somehow they somehow
some way
to make it all work they fit in a role
play their role and then
all the success comes and that one guy
that's leaving
you know what i mean supposed to get his
flowers